you have just seen what's happening in
Texas in Florida and now we're told that
the White House coronavirus task force
has recommendations for stricter
measures in those in other states none
publicized report recommends 18 states
18 should close the bars and gyms and
impacted counties and asked residents to
wear a mask at all times when you're
outside of your house we should Jiang is
at the White House we when did the task
force get this information good morning
to you good morning to you and good
morning to everybody well this latest
report was dated for this past Tuesday
but we know that the document was first
prepared for the coronavirus task force
and has reportedly been shared at this
point with the federal government dr.
deborah birx who has referenced earlier
versions of it says it is actually
updated weekly and shared with
governor's many of whom are dealing with
devastating spikes in cases no
administration in history has removed
more red tape more quickly to rescue the
economy and to protect the health of our
people as president Trump praised his
administration's response to the corona
virus pandemic Maryland's Republican
governor Larry Hogan gave him a
blistering review I think those are some
of the biggest mistakes that that the
president made throughout this pandemic
and that was not following the advice of
the the experts the doctors the
scientists Hogan also wrote a scathing
essay claiming that the president was
more concerned about boosting the stock
market or his reelection plans the
criticism comes as a White House
document dated Tuesday shows eleven
states are in the red zone for having
more than 10% of test results come back
positive and as a new report from the
CDC confirms the virus had been
spreading widely in New York City by the
time the Trump administration imposed
travel restrictions from Europe the
agency faults the country's limited
testing abilities for leaving many cases
undetected now four months later there's
a new testing problem
I worry that when people have to wait
seven days or longer
there's no spreading the disease
unknowingly ultimately we can give the
states the supplies but they've got to
use them and the best way possible to
get results as quickly as possible I
just think that it was avoidable
Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg blasted the
federal response to the corona virus in
a chat Thursday with dr. Anthony Falchi
question whose television appearances
have been blocked by the White House
over the past three months and it's
really disappointing that we still don't
have adequate testing that the
credibility of our top scientists like
yourself in the CDC are being undermined
and then until recently that parts of
the administration we're calling into
question whether people should even
follow basic best practices like wearing
nuts
we really got almost regroup call a
timeout we've got to get our arms around
this and we've got to get this control
Facebook is often a source of
misinformation about the corona virus
the platform announced that this week it
is launching a new section to set the
record straight with facts about Cova 19
CBS News has also learned doctor foul G
and the president spoke by phone earlier
this week their first conversation in a
month and a half Anthony we just hang at
the White House thanks we should